is going on yes to me sometimes I'm like
you're right the girl is like but the
guy's like you're just dumb bro like
Adam Levine's girl is like yeah I knew
what it was yeah hey what's going on I'm
like so I'm not gonna ashamed like for
me it's like I'm not gonna shame those
guys for doing that but like people
think I'm confusing that with like
saying oh you should cheat you drank the
Kool-Aid I'm like I didn't drink the
Kool-Aid I just that's what the world is
and so it is what it is I think I think
the hardest part to me is I just don't
like you're right it's like a naive
thing but I gotta be 100 honest there
are some athletes who don't do it there
are some not all of them is it one
percent two percent I don't know the
number right yeah are some apps so so to
me what I don't like and I I love I love
about I love guys being honest yeah
don't play like you're the nice guy who
doesn't cheered after the game I just go
home and sleep and watch Netflix like
don't lie okay but Devil's Advocate I I
think women we know when dude's getting
laid stop it stop out there stop it we
and like what they'll do is they'll
pretend like oh oh I didn't know I had
no idea why'd you check his phone 10
times stop it you you knew like there's
a part of you you knew he was gonna
cheat you did not get bamboozled you
just like the guy that can cheat and and
I won't feel bad for you and I think the
amount of times I've been on the show
the girls love the cheaters because I
swear to God I've had girl after girl
after girl it's like they love telling
these stories they look they love they
love that's always the acts they talk
about the most and hate is closer to
love so it's like you love him here here
I I it's funny enough I was on
jedediah's podcast and she played a clip
that you played about women loving
cheaters here is the reality there's a
clip about women loving cheaters you
were talking to this one girl about life
oh she played me on the podcast oh I
didn't I didn't know I was okay yeah I
didn't I didn't know I was on the show
yeah yeah yeah you know what I'm talking
about I talk for 16 hours a week okay
she knows you don't know anyway so she's
playing a clip of you that you talk
about how women love cheaters uh-huh and
so you made that point but it's not that
she loves the cheater she loved the
cheater then she wouldn't complain about
the cheater what she loves is what the
cheater brings to her right so usually
well there is some of that but usually
who's a cheater is a cheater you know
Joe Blow working at McDonald's that
these women are crazy about sometimes
it's not trust me it's not if it was
joking you'll be surprised some bombs
have a lot of free time but here's a
reaction there's one guy that came on my
show he was telling me about his
rotation I'm right this man barely was a
huge SoundCloud rapper but here's a
hypnosis
women call men bones but they don't
really understand women are seeing in
him oh just because you don't have a job
doesn't mean that you're bumped woman
you might be Saucy he might be swaggy he
might have a certain genocide being
charismatic he's a big they have the
time to do it exactly so to me there's a
level of attraction yeah true that these
men have true and when you and when you
can attract her you can attract her her
her and her and so to the point of men
women just liking to cheat her women
like men who other women want and the
men the other women want are usually the
men who will want to cheat so therefore
it's I just want to bring bring that to
the equation because I don't it's just
not simply like because I know there's a
guy like well I'm gonna cheat on my
girlfriend and then she didn't want me
no bro she's not gonna want you no
matter what you do you're not attracted
to her that's your problem go find
somebody else but it's you become if
you're really that guy and other women
do find you attractive that is some of
the things that's when you hear these
women tell the story because that guy
turned them on so much yeah but the
problem is it's like I ask it's like I
I've done these shows so many times I
just see the same story in different
people I'm sure you've had a similar
like 100 yeah and it's the same story
like okay he cheated did you leave no
when did you leave when he stopped like
like you ask enough questions they
always leave when he stops cheating or
he's not cheating it's like why don't
you leave when he cheated no here's what
happened here's what happened it's not
that they left when he stopped cheating
they left when she can mostly be mostly
detached so here's what happens a woman
will be with a guy cheats on her hurts
on her because it continues to hurt her
she cannot leave at that moment she
mostly attached to her she cannot go
from
she has to solely pull away and slowly
detach but in the meantime she doesn't
want to rock the boat she won't think
that she's about to leave but she'd be
nice she'd be sweet should be to be kind
so in that season usually I found that's
when the guy's chilling out he's like
you know what I'm chilling out you know
to me I'm not doing as much not in the
streets as much she's getting better
we're getting better you think if he
cheated again she would still like she
would leave Ben I think I I like so so
say like he cheats once and then the
second time he cheats do you think she
would leave because depending on the
woman depending on her back or depending
on her mental state depending on how
much she loves chaos depending on if
it's so many different yeah no it's just
like the the thing with me is like a lot
of them will say he did it multiple
times but they always leave when he
stops well and it's just it's just weird
but it's not true that the moment he
stopped cheating because how would she
know he stopped cheating she she was
always
the moment the moment that's that's the
moment the moment like she stops finding
evidence of him yeah it's just weird to
me here's what I'm saying what I've
learned is talking this is why I stopped
doing a lot of things that I did when
you talk when you're talking to women
and you're doing these interviews and
you have these lights and you have these
beautiful black magic cameras they're
not going to tell you the honest truth
and when you give women direct questions
in front of Lights in front of a camera
they're not telling the truth that's why
all due respect to your guy I didn't
want to do a show not because I don't
want to shout him out if he had a
one-on-one Pockets I would do it but
women are not as honest in front of
Lights in front of the cameras because
for them expressing logical truths is
not the best if you want to express
emotions ask her the better question was
okay when you eventually left him how
did you feel about him and when did that
feeling start because usually what you
figure out is that that emotion was
dying she cut it off months ago it was
dying off I agree with you and so see so
she stopped searching for cheating yeah
she stopped caring about the thing
because she was mostly checked out I
don't know I just I think like sometimes
as women we kind of like the drama on
healthy women do I I just think yeah
there's a part of Do You Love drama do
you want do you love a man who's gonna
keep on cheating on you smacking you up
beside your head calling you names oh
God you said drama
a lot of drama some people you say they
love drama what more is better
hey some people like it that sounds like
it would hurt some people like it
um do you like it do I like drama yeah
like ever I mean I watched the
Kardashians
I think there's some innate part of
women in general that tends to like
drama I'm not saying all women of course
they like drama but here's a reality
people are using that word drama
incorrectly what's going on is that for
healthy women like yourself you to
describe your father shout out to your
father and your beautiful mother shout
out dad respect you see Dad and Jen come
on now come on that's funny my mom
later on today I'm 25. chill out listen
you ain't too grown for it but see
that's that white girl yeah
in a black world
it's like over 21. oh no you get it
actually you don't shut up Nigeria my
whole content team is not in Nigeria
but but here's what I'll here's what
I'll say about the about the drama part
yeah part
healthy women women always go back to
what's normal to them yeah everybody can
like a little bit of drama but a healthy
woman such as yourself if a man keeps on
cheating on her calling you out your
name you ain't staying there but a girl
came from a broken background a broken
household where that's normal that is
home for her women always go back home
so to your point yes some women do like
a very toxic unhealthy drama but I would
argue women like yourself who come from
healthy backgrounds is only so much
drama they can take before they're going
to lead this individual yeah no I think
you're right I just think like this
isn't this is very as many of you know I
was just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible